brani spears his father didn't want her
going on a recent vacation to hawaii
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
according to court documents obtained by
e.t brittany's lawyer michael rosengaard
said jaime didn't want his daughter to
take a trip to maui in late july
he thought the short vacation was
unnecessary even though the trip would
have come from his daughters
own hard earned money anyone who follows
the 39 year old pop star on social media
knows how much brit loves to travel to
hawaii
i'm swimming and i'm on your back i'm a
shark
baby while approval for her recent
trip was ultimately granted britney's
lawyer says
the dispute caused understandable
anguish to the pop star
and this objection emphasized why
removing jamie from her conservatorship
is an urgent matter so urgent that
matthew filed a motion
requesting that the judge expedite
jaime's removal as conservator of her
estate
ahead of the scheduled september 29th
hearing in his place brittany requests
that jason rubin
step in as temporary conservator she
asked that the court remove her father
as early as the court will permit or on
or
after august 23rd quote although a
two-month wait for a hearing on the
petition
may not seem significant in the context
of 13 years
miss spears should not be forced to
continue to feel traumatized
lose sleep and suffer further he wrote
in the filing
every day matters i once again want to
thank
britney spears for her courage and for
her strength
and i also want to thank britney spears
fans and supporters
outreach and support for my firm myself
and most importantly brittany has truly
been overwhelming finally and the last
thing i'm going to say about
this matter is as i said in court
last week and outside my firm and i are
moving
aggressively and expeditiously
to file a petition to remove jamie
spears
unless he resigns first thank you the
document also states that if jamie
chooses to put his daughter's well-being
first
and accept an outcome that does not even
ask him to admit to fault
britney can begin to have a semblance of
her life back
among the 39-year-old pop star's claims
against the conservatorship
include a tight reign over her finances
her career
her personal life and even her
reproductive
decisions in brittany's bombshell
testimony in june
she told the court that she's forced to
have an iud so that she cannot have
children
and has not been permitted to marry she
also referenced her desire to
drive again claiming she's been unable
to do so under her conservatorship
i love driving my car something about
being able to drive your car that allows
freedom
[Music]
and i haven't been able to drive my car
but that's all changed
the singer was recently spotted freely
driving in los angeles
and britt also gave an update on the
conservatorship on instagram
okay so i'm sure a lot of you guys are
wondering how i'm doing and since the
cat is out of the bag
literally out of the bag um and you guys
know my situation
um i do want to let you guys know things
are way better than what i ever
[Music]
anticipated
you